the governor of Sudan's West R4 region
has been killed Sudan's Army says that
the paramilitary rapid support forces
was behind his death kamis Ibaka was
killed in elginina he'd earlier
described the situation in the city as
genocide the area has seen some of the
worst violence since the war started in
April more than a thousand people have
been killed in the region
pepper Morgan has more from ondarman
the governor of West Darfur hamis
abbakar was the head of Sudan's
Liberation movement and army one of the
Rebel groups that signed a peace
agreement with the Sudanese government
in 2020 after which he was appointed as
governor of westar4 now hours before
videos of his killing started
circulating on Wednesday he gave media
statements to describe the situation on
the ground specifically in the city of
Janina as genocide the Sudanese Army has
accused the rapid support forces of
being behind the killing of the governor
now many people have fled from from the
city of Janina into neighboring Chad and
they accuse Arab militias Allied to the
rapid support forces of targeting People
based on their ethnicities in the city
of Janina the governor himself was from
the masalita tribe the tribe which
survivors accused the Arab militias of
targeting at least a thousand people
have been killed since the start of the
violence in mid-april and thousands of
others have been injured but due to a
lack of Access to Health Facilities
doctors say that they were not able to
reach those who've been injured many
people say that the humanitarian
situation continues to deteriorate in
West Darfur as fighting continues
between Arab militias and and a few from
the masalita tribe now survivors also
accused the Sudanese Army of not acting
to protect them they say that the Army
has been barricaded in their Barracks
since the start of the Arab militias
targeting people from the masalis tribe
and have called on the International
Community to respond to the crisis that
is unfolding in West Darfur specifically
in Janina Hebrew Morgan Al Jazeera on
durman